this is really interesting I guess the
fact that we have these three buckets
the number of critical resources the
number of critical bytes and path links
illustrate that there's really no one
Golden Rule
for example if I eliminate the number of
critical resources I would also probably
reduce the number of bytes and likewise
if I start compressing and caching and
minifying I could also reduce the number
of bytes exactly I couldn't have said it
better myself I think you're really
starting to get a hang of this let's try
a few more examples okay same page but
now with CSS and JavaScript once again
we get the HTML and discover CSS and
JavaScript resources and initiate those
requests
note that the JavaScript file is a bit
smaller than the CSS so it may arrive
sooner but javascript is blocked on the
CSS on being created right correct
once the CSS arrives the browser builds
the CSS object model which unblocked
JavaScript and allows it to execute once
the JavaScript is executed the Dom
parser becomes unblocked which means a
complete Dom construction and finally we
have both the DOM and the CSS object
model which means that we can render the
page as you can see even a simple page
such as this one has a lot of
dependencies that slow down the critical
path and no kidding